hey guys it's desa found a thick hair
and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of Thor the dark world
that the second Thor Thor to normal
phase two yes yes so I'm you know before
we get into any type of spoilers and
stuff let's just talk about in general
terms what do you think of it I liked it
I thought it was great i liked it even
better than the first not like so much
better but it was a little bit better
tons of comedy way more common that
thought it would be I mean Alan Taylor
coming over director on Twitter comin
from Game of Thrones and thought it
might be a little bit like the trailer
looks a little dark like the dark world
it's gonna be dark but there's comedy
like they never let it get too serious
which I liked yeah I enjoyed it as well
and I think it I liked it a little bit
more than the first one but it's on par
with it you know I do you think they
were there was more and better action in
this one than the first one felt bigger
because in the first one I felt like it
if peak action wise kind of in the
beginning or that in the beginning but I
forgot when they fought the the frost
giants right yeah and that was like the
best scene of the first one in the end
sequence wasn't that great right where
this one it kind of builds in the best
action sequences are you know then at
the end was pretty cool yeah i mean this
movie feels bigger it feels more epic in
scope i mean i won't spoil anything but
even that the opening sequence very lord
of the rings that's very like you just
kind of been yet with a storytelling and
it just feel like kind of like a lord of
the rings battle I'm of course as you
know from the trailers and other elves
involved so it was good i mean
everything is just bigger and better
special effects i mean i thought it was
just great let the writing was strong
it's good i did I thought Kevin Brennan
being away I was a little bit worried
both Alan Taylor I did a good job yeah I
mean you're right about the comedy it's
there's a lot of comedy in there some
people might find it too much yeah if
you're you know maybe like a die-hard
comic book fan you're like wow this yeah
this may be silly yeah maybe you want it
to be more serious and little silly the
main story for me just wasn't anything
really that's special it was just kind
of like right they did it so they can
have some cool action sequences that was
one weakest I
I think I'm a butcher's name is a clean
honey say his last name the bad guy Oh
ecklestein a cocinar sales way up on the
clothes um you know doctor who fans know
he's done other things who's a good
actor strong actor his cat really wasn't
well-developed now he's just kind of the
MU I'm going to bring the universe to
darkness I'm like but why like what
exactly like I remember I was arguing
with some people online they were saying
like well they explained that you know
they you know that the Dark Elves lived
in a time of darkness and they want to
bring about again I'm like okay yy-yeah
it so I get it but what's so good about
the darkness why did they hate the
lights on my thing give me some little
more explanation yeah or just motivation
right okay it was better for them yeah
how was it better for them why does this
guy in particular why is he the leader
why does he want to do that so yeah
other people follow him why did they
yeah all this stuff yeah so yeah for me
the villain it wasn't his fault but like
the villain was kind of more of a plot
device it was is to serve the fact i
will get up into this more in the
spoiler section but it was to serve more
the plot device of getting thorn low key
to team up to which and typical comic
book fashion think that's why we you
know i probably little forgiving of it
is because it's that's how a lot of [ __ ]
books are a lot of the villains and calm
books until nowadays aren't really well
developed there's a muha like you know
evil i'm evil guys I mean until modern
comics a little more well developed but
you know it's what you kind of expect
from a comic book you know it's fine but
I would have liked because of the actor
I do like him I think he could have done
more they could have given it more to do
and speaking of thorn loci that dynamic
is awesome it's narrating in this in
this movie it's it's the best dynamic
that the Marvel Universe has right now
because it's this thing where Loki's the
villain but he's not really the villain
everybody loves them people have them
the girls are the girls love him more
than of Chris Hemsworth right I mean
he's the guy that when he comes on
screen people kind of cheer get excited
I Cole I'm sure let people saw the
comic-con video of him doing that whole
thing like save IT Crowd just goes nuts
because they just really love well cuz
there's depth to his character because
he's not just oh I'm an evil villain
rights like no he's more of a tortured
person who has you know a lot of the
things that he does
that you know that are considered bad or
evil there's a purpose or reason because
of you know he feels spurned by his
father that is yeah daddy issues and
jealousy of his envious of his brother
and that's what the the villain in this
movie I thought lacked a little nothing
I'd have the same story Loki could add a
whole different story but because he's
just so evil you know and dark I'm like
gotta give me a little something they
look because it'd be funny now but give
him give me something more round yeah
and uh so yeah I thought the action was
good comedy was good visual effects are
really good thinking ella taylor did it
did a really good job with it i think
pacing was good i think the story could
have been done better right but i think
it was just to serve to serve everything
else sure yeah I would I kind of wish we
could have seen more of the warriors 3
yeah that was a big event from the first
one we got a little bit more from this
yeah but it's still not enough I want to
see more sippy yeah we got more jaimie
alexander who should be wonder woman but
you know I would have liked a little bit
more of her yes and I also there's the
kind of hinted at this this love
triangle between Thor Jane Foster and
SIF you know SIF is in love with or with
Jane and she's jealous a shame myself I
like yeah you know the comments i love
lady SIF I'm sorry Jane Foster I'm sorry
I just I can't well she I think she's a
better fit for Thor yeah lose about the
same length of period of yeah and you
know she's just you know lives that same
lifestyle I mean I still haven't I mean
that's another weakness and this comes
from the first movie as well as new
Thorne Jane Foster's relationship there
there love interleague yeah there's even
dynamic about net I mean I love natalie
portman gorgeous he's gorgeous is great
actors to lake as a character they're
doing nothing she's smart she's a smart
scientist lady but sip is like this is a
badass warrior woman I mean I just don't
feel the chemistry there right not that
it's bad it's not like Tom Hanks Audrey
tatou in da Vinci Code bad no but but at
the same time there's nothing there
where you know you got like a robert
downey jr west Paltrow and iron that's a
good relationship so great you get a
nice day
make going there I don't get that from
this right yeah Portman in the role she
I feel like it's one of those roles that
you could put like she's almost taking a
vacation because we know she can add
seen black swan I know she's great but
it feels like she doesn't really need to
do that much just kind of in the movie
you know I think you'd almost put any
actress in there but i don't know i mean
hopefully the sip and Thor 3 we know
there I know marbles working on fourth
or threes hopefully we'll see some more
of us if the next one yeah and then also
yet kat dennings as Darcy she was kind
of comedic relief but the thing is then
you even had a stellan skarsgard you
know crazy yeah still crazy it's also
comic relief and there's just a lot of
color I want a butcher's name buddy of
the actor I came think I was the actor
from he's in girls' on HBO says he's an
irish actor I think he's Irish has
another show on HBO that just was
released recently small comedy who plays
a the import ya know plays a Portman's
um goes on a date with Portman oh oh so
down crystal down for miles bridesmaids
bright that's a [ __ ] movie that he's
known for but he was great he's a
comedic actor and he's great they had
the comedic it wasn't just like banter
like Joss Whedon writes it was more like
he's really comedic set pieces yeah I
mean no were really well done i was
surprised by that okay well let's let's
give our over you overview and grades
before we get into a spoiler section
personally i'm gonna give it a b-plus i
think it's it's very entertaining
enjoyable a lot of good comedy it's a
good pace a lot of good action only
complaints are like the story could be
better than it could be better you're
definitely not going to see this movie
for awesome story yeah um the Thor Loki
dynamic i think is is the best part of
the story wise and character wise but
yeah I think you should check it out
yeah I give it name- it give it a little
bit higher I liked a lot more than the
first you know I still like the first I
just loved the mythology behind it I
love the comedy so I would give him more
the action was better I actually enjoyed
this more than iron man 3 not to set it
out not to say that I'm in 3c the words
that I meant it is a good movie hope
y'all didn't I gave a better performance
maybe than Hemsworth pages because this
performance called for more than just
being you know what
is doing but I like I just had more fun
of this movie I want to go see star trek
into darkness yeah a lot of fun this
yeah yeah so I get a minus okay alright
so let's get into some spoilers yeah old
section so if you've already seen them
you know if you haven't seen the movie
go check it out if you if you already
have then stick around with us so what
were your favorite sequences their
scenes favorite scenes again there's
some of the small comedic set pieces I
loved towards the end when Thor goes
into Jane's I guess it's her mother's
apartment in like he's just kind of he's
just such a fish out of water a key he
just like hey he's just like co trapeze
like just like hangs his hammer and we
didn't crush it but you know that it's
just some of the small committee moment
when Thor was going into the train
station at the end and you know just
like what's the way to get to Greenwich
it's like oh it's three ways like it's
just all when he gets in the car with
Jane fine it's all like big and kind of
uncomfortable and doing this and he's
like who's young you know a sum of the
moments or just it was just a comedy it
came ok so after low-key dies yeah you
know or well yeah he doesn't you know it
doesn't die um but it's all a somber
then that came together and then all of
a sudden you know their phone rings and
that rap music comes on like it never it
never got too serious which i like how
about you worry some of your favorites
yeah you had the kind of the warping of
the you know that when they warp Darcy
kiss yeah inter was good that was funny
let's talk about you know Loki's death
so we at the end they reveal that he's
not dead I me for the trailers trailers
reveal so much like you know in Thor got
his hand cut you know it really wasn't i
mean you kind of knew they were planning
something but was well done though I
thought the actors did a great job I
love like solo their chemistry it was a
great trick you know they had you know
they can't kill low key cuz he's so
well-loved right maybe you know all the
especially like the fangirls are gonna
go crazy good deal Bors Odin see that's
the thing is that's the question there
what happened to him I don't think he's
dead no I I think if he had died they
would have shown it oh you did that one
moment where he was like uh look he had
that grunty kind of Deline like you tell
he's good he's getting old I think he's
imprisoned I think
uh I think Loki took him and put him
somewhere I don't know where hit him
away in some sort of prison yeah and and
that's I don't think he's dead but you
know they kind of ended it so that door
3 right yeah we'll get to see Loki
somehow maybe as Odin controlling things
from behind the scene yeah I don't know
I don't know if he's gonna be the main
villain again or yeah it'll be probably
like in there he said he already said he
wasn't gonna be involved in Avengers 2
he's not have a big role and he maybe
he'll show up but he's not gonna have a
big girl they're gonna focus on
something else so yeah I don't know that
it's age of Ultron that makes sense
maybe with Avengers 3 when they do say
no sand everything speaking of Thanos
there was two and credit scenes or after
credits one was kind of mid-credits one
was at the end the one at the end is
just kind of silly yeah it's it's it's
not like anything major no it's just the
Warren Jane Foster kissing and I that
monster thing chasing birds the
mid-credits scene on that hand was
significant because it plays into the
whole guardians of the galaxy these you
know personally I found it kind of silly
i I don't know why but it looked like
they shot it on a lesser camera there
because Thor 2 was shot on a Alexa I
could tell from the after credits scene
that it was definitely not the same
standard right hammer and I wouldn't let
that be a sign of what gardens the
galaxy I'm sure that was probably rushed
a little bit cuz Benicio at comic-con
just said that he was I mean I think he
had just been at London just recently
getting ready to start shooting so I'm
sure they'd probably like just pump that
out real fast but I mean just seen
Benicio acting all crazy i love bini so
he's one of my favorite actors so I just
seen him acting all crazy as a collector
I'm I'm happy to see that in the fully
realized movie you know I mean this was
just kind of like you know whatever but
it does date into the whole thing about
the Infinity stones yeah it's gonna be
gauntlet now he has one of you know he
and how they're changing it because in
in the comic book series they had
different gems you know like a soul gem
and of whatever Jam I can't reveal the
names but in this they're taking
existing like power sources like that
iraq / Cosmic Cube making that one of
the infinity gems right taking this
ether and making an infinite gem so
they're taking these these other
existing entities and drain those into
the power sources for the infinite
gotland right versus what what it was in
the comic books here right yeah it's
changed a little bit i mean that's
that's a series i never got a chance to
read I'd like you can pick it up on
comiXology right here on amazon whatever
even good at the whole i want to read it
but yeah I think that's gonna meet you
to see I'm excited for guardians the GAO
accessible cuz that got me excited
seeing all that i guess we i need to
mention who talked about favorite scenes
need to mention i'm sure people will get
on us if we don't mention this is that
the captain america cameo oh yeah i
forgot about that you got him in yeah
that was hella great actually that was
probably when i laughed the most yeah
was that statement Linda Stephens yeah
Chris Evans imitating low key or tom
hiddleston plain low key and I thought
it was pretty pretty funny that'd be
curious uh you know I have to think your
community if you went to see it imax 3d
like dennis and i just did if you saw
the captain america footage was maybe
five minutes five minutes five minute
fight sequence elevator looks good yeah
yeah we'll see how many that's that's
the next one we'll see i thought the
fight scene with a free go was pretty
cool even though his short i know like
her neighbors was gone now I wanted her
to be a alive Stokes I really I was like
oh they finally gave her something to do
and she was badass yeah it was a short
sequence but it was pretty cool ya
kicked him I'll kits ah yeah took him
down yeah and I like her funeral
sequence to like it was like a Viking
funeral idea I mean this movie's
basically lower the Rings and Star Wars
kind of meshed to any elements of those
movies message agreements words thrown
in there Taylor doing game of thrones is
great yeah i hope he directs next one I
I hope so too i think after this they
will just do really well i think he'll
get a lot more offers now cuz they're
like oh he can do it you know we do a
big-budget movie so yeah I mean my
favorite parts were those thorne low key
scenes especially when their net that uh
kind of like Star Wars gifting the fight
yeah yeah when they're going towards
that secret entrance or that yeah secret
path that only Loki knows how to get out
of Asgard and well when Jane Foster is
kind of out of it right already in the
dark
oh yeah and they're just having this
conversations about you know how much
how much you could tell that they still
care for each other but they hate each
other and Thor doesn't really hate low
key he just can't trust them and that he
just look he's just envious and just but
they are brought together by their bond
of right of their mother dying which I
thought was great i mean with Loki one
of my favorite scenes was when Loki
reveals how he really is after i know
there's yeah like that yeah authority
try to give this this impression that oh
I'm fine and Laura Thoren knew it he
called him out he's like I know you're
not fine on this yeah yeah I'll to I
gotta give us a shout out to Idris
Elba's nice to get I'm Dale get a little
bit more you know a little more screen
time a little bit more I mean I love him
as an actor I just feel I just think
it's kind of a waste because he's
because in Marvel they can't they don't
use the same they won't use the same
actor in a different role and so now you
have a jurist elbow as handle individual
exactly I feel like he should be a lead
character in in another Marvel movie
versus side character there were two
guys I mean the guy who was the melt my
keep saying about kiss of death so the
guy they dealt the dark out is his
right-hand man from Los yeah yeah who is
African and it was a good actor I he's
another guys like two guys this movie
I'm like man he's got to be great black
panther guys I don't know if we'll ever
see if that ever happens but I was gonna
do both great guys for black grandpa
yeah that's too late now there are ya ya
already can already cast and the reason
why I like a ray stevenson can play
another card even though he was
Punishers cuz the punisher wasn't under
Marvel's banner when he great and I
doubt anybody unless you really know who
he is would recognize like that Sarah
Stevenson unit yeah it's a similar with
like Chris Evans like he was Johnny
Storm Human Torch but that was under Fox
for brett has like four and now he's
kept their America okay so but these two
now now it just robbed was under the
Marvel banner so yeah can't be someone
else which i think is unfortunate which
also obsessed me about jaimie alexander
perhaps maybe she can get out of this
and do
you know do both i would love her if you
could do both days lady SIF and also be
wonder woman but that could be I could
be dreaming on that I think she could do
one of them because I think she's not a
major character in the movie or even in
this franchise and maybe under her
contract she can do something like that
yeah alright guys so you can post your
comments below on the website I think
caricom or on our youtube youtube
channel think hero pro make sure you
subscribe to that and we're also on
Twitter you can kind of chat with us i'm
at thank Hera I'm at Griffin de and we
also have a Facebook page that's a
facebook.com slash think your old fans
make sure you like that page and share
our videos and tweet it and all that
good stuff